من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجيه لواء دوري ما
التاثيرات المتوقعه لصواريخ بعيده المدى
في حال فعلا زودت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه القوات الاوكرانيه بها
يعني الان لو عدنا اشهر الى الوراء عندما
تم التزويد بمنظومه مارس كانت الميداليات
ضمن مسافه 80 كم تعتبر اهداف
وادت الى نتائج ايجابيه بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني لان اتمكنت من تدمير معظم
مستودعات الذخيره ونقاط التكديس واصابه
القوافل وبالتالي حدث ارباك منذ معركه
خارف كيف ازيوم وخرسم وكذلك بفعل همم
هيمارس بصوره رئيسيه الان نتحدث عن مدى
150 كلم اي بمعنى اخر ان كافه المنظومه
اللوجستيه
والاداريه
وكافه التعزيزات ضمن هذا المدى ستكون
بمتناول هذه القذائف وبالتالي هذا سنعكس
اذا ما تحقق
اما التزويد سيدنعكس على المعارك لاحظ في
الفتره الحاليه اليد العليا نسبيا هي
للجانب الروسي في معظم مناطق دونيست
وبالتالي هذه
الذخائر اذا وصلت في الوقت المناسب ستساعد
في اعاده التوازن الميداني ما بين طرفي
الصراع